this is
henry a cute boy and when henry was
three his mom found him having
some febrile seizures febrile seizures
are seizures that occur
when you also have a fever and the
doctor said
don't worry too much kids usually
outgrow these
when he was four he had a convulsive
seizure
the kind that you lose consciousness and
shake
generalized tonic clonic seizure and
while the diagnosis of epilepsy
was in the mail henry's mom went to
get him out of bed one morning and as
she went
in his room she found his
cold lifeless body
henry died of sudep sudden unexpected
death and epilepsy
i'm curious how many of you have heard
of sudep
this is a very well educated audience
and i see only
a few hands suit up is when a
otherwise healthy person with epilepsy
dies and they can't attribute it to
anything they can find in an autopsy
there is a suit up every seven to nine
minutes
that's on average two per ted talk
now a normal brain has electrical
activity
you can see some of the electrical waves
coming out of this
picture of a brain here and these should
look like typical
electrical activity that an eeg could
read on the surface
when you have a seizure it's a bit of
unusual electrical activity and it can
be focal it can take place in just a
small part of your brain
when that happens you might have a
strange sensation
uh one could be happening several could
be happening here in the audience right
now and the person next to you might not
even know
however if you have a seizure where that
little brush fire
spreads like a forest fire over the
brain then it generalizes
and that generalized seizure takes your
consciousness away and causes you to
convulse
there are more suit ups in the united
states
every year than sudden infant death
syndrome
now how many of you have heard of sudden
infant death syndrome right
pretty much every hand goes up so what's
going on here
why is this so much more common and yet
people haven't heard of it and what can
you do to prevent it
well there are two things scientifically
shown that prevent
or reduce the risk of sudep the first
is follow your doctor's instructions
take your medications
two-thirds of people who have epilepsy
get it under control
with their medications the second thing
that reduces the risk of suit up is
companionship
it's having somebody there at the time
that you have a seizure now sudep
even though most of you have never heard
of it is actually the number two
cause of years of potential life lost of
all neurological disorders uh the
vertical axis
is the number of deaths times the
remaining lifespan so higher
is much worse impact suit up however
unlike these others is something that
people right here could do
something to push that down
now what is uh what is raz picard as
an ai researcher doing here telling you
about sudep right i'm not a neurologist
when i was working at the media lab on
measurement of emotion trying to make
our machines more intelligent about our
emotions
we started doing a lot of work measuring
stress
we built lots of sensors that measured
it in lots of different ways
but one of them in particular grew out
of
some of this very old work with
measuring sweaty palms with an
electrical signal
this is a signal skin conductance that's
known to go up when you get nervous
but it turns out it also goes up with a
lot of other interesting conditions
but measuring it with wires on your hand
is really inconvenient so we
invented a bunch of other ways of doing
this at the mit media lab
and with these wearables we started to
collect the first ever clinical quality
data
24 7. here's a picture of what that
looked like the first
time that an mit student collected skin
conductance on the wrist
24 7. let's zoom in a little bit here
what you see is 24 hours from left to
right and here's two days of data
and first what surprised us was
the sleep was the biggest peak of the
day now that sounds broken right
how i mean you're calm when you're
asleep so what's going on here
well it turns out that our physiology
during sleep is very different than our
physiology during wake
and while there's still a bit of a
mystery why these peaks are usually the
biggest
of the day during sleep we now believe
they're related to memory consolidation
and memory formation during sleep we
also saw things that were exactly what
we
expected when an mit student is working
hard in the lab or on homeworks
there it's not only emotional stress but
there's cognitive load
and it turns out that cognitive load
cognitive effort mental engagement
excitement about learning something
those things also make the signal go up
unfortunately to the embarrassment of we
mit professors
the low point everyday uh classroom
activity
now i am just showing you one person's
data here but this unfortunately is true
uh in general
this sweat band has inside it a
home-built skin conductance sensor
and one day one of our undergrads
knocked on my door right at the end of
the december semester
and he said professor picard could i
please borrow one of your
wristband sensors my little brother has
autism
he can't talk and i want to see what's
stressing him out
and i said sure in fact don't just take
one take two
because they broke easily back then so
he took them home he put them on his
little brother now i was back in mit
looking at the data
on my laptop and the first day
i thought i thought he put them on both
wrists instead of waiting for one to
break
okay fine don't follow my instructions
i'm glad he didn't
second day chill looked like classroom
activity
a few more days ahead the next day
one wrist signal was flat and the other
had the biggest peak i've ever seen
and i thought what's going on we've
stressed people out at mit every way
imaginable
i've never seen a peak this big
and it was only on one side how can you
be stressed on one side of your body not
the other
so i thought one or both sensors must be
broken
now i'm an electrical engineer by
training so i started a whole bunch of
stuff to try to debug this
and long story short i could not
reproduce this
so i resorted to old-fashioned debugging
i called the student at home
on vacation hi uh
how's your little brother how's your
christmas hey do you have
any idea what happened to him and i gave
this particular date and time
in the data and he said i don't know
i'll check
the diary diary mit student keeps a
diary
uh so i waited and he came back he had
the exact date and time and he says
that was right before he had a grand mal
seizure
now at the time i didn't know anything
about epilepsy
and did a bunch of research realized
that another student's dad is chief of
neurosurgery at children's hospital
boston
screwed up my courage and called dr joe
madison hi dr madsen my name is rosalind
picard
uh is it possible somebody could have
a huge sympathetic nervous system
surge that's what drives the skin
conductance
uh 20 minutes before a seizure
and he says probably not
he says it's interesting we've had
people whose hair stands on end
on one arm 20 minutes before a seizure
and i'm like on one arm i didn't want to
tell him uh that initially because i
thought he'd
this was too ridiculous he explained how
this could happen in the brain
and he got interested showed him the
data we made a whole bunch more devices
got them safety certified
90 families were being enrolled in a
study all with children who were going
to be monitored 24 7 with gold standard
eeg on their scalp for reading the brain
activity
video to watch the behavior
ecg and now eda electrodermal activity
to see
if there was something in this periphery
that we could easily pick up related to
a seizure
we found in 100 of the first
batch of grand mal seizures these
whopper of responses in the skin
conductance
the blue in the middle the boy's sleep
is usually the biggest peak of the day
these three seizures you see here are
popping out of the forest like redwood
trees
furthermore when you couple the skin
conductance at the top
with the movement from the wrist
and you get lots of data and train
machine learning and ai on it
you can build an automated ai that
detects these
patterns much better than just a shake
detector can do so we realized
that we needed to get this out and with
the phd work of ming zapo
and later great improvements by impatica
this has made progress and the seizure
detection is much more accurate
but we also learned some other things
about sudap during this one thing we
learned
is that sudep is while it's rare after a
generalized tonic clonic seizure
that's when it's most likely to happen
after that type
and when it happens it doesn't happen
during the seizure
and it doesn't usually happen in
immediately afterwards but immediately
afterwards when the person just seems
very still and quiet
they may go into another phase
where the breathing stops and then after
the breathing stops
later the heart stops so there's some
time to get somebody there
we also learned that there is a region
deep in the brain called the amygdala
which we have been studying in our
emotion research a lot
we have two amygdalas and if you
stimulate the right one you get a big
right skin conductance response now you
have to sign up right now for a
craniotomy to get this done
not exactly something we're going to
volunteer to do but it causes a big
right skin conductance response
stimulating the left one big left skin
conductance response on the palm
and furthermore when somebody stimulates
your amygdala
while you're sitting there and you might
just be working
you don't show any signs of distress but
you stop breathing
and you don't start again until somebody
stimulates you
hey roz are you there and you open your
mouth to talk
as you take that breath to speak you
start breathing again
so we had started with work on stress
which had
enabled us to build lots of sensors that
were gathering high quality enough data
that we could leave the lab and start to
get this in the wild
accidentally found whopper of a response
with a seizure
neurological activation that can cause a
much bigger response than traditional
stressors
lots of partnership with hospitals and
epilepsy monitoring unit
especially children's hospital boston
and the brigham and machine learning and
ai
on top of this to take and collect lots
more
data in service of trying to understand
these events and if we could prevent
sudap
this is now commercialized by impatica
a startup that i've had the privilege to
co-found and the team there has done an
amazing job improving the technology to
make a very beautiful
sensor that not only tells time and does
steps and uh
sleep and all that good stuff but this
is running real-time ai and machine
learning
to detect generalized tonic-clonic
seizures and
send an alert for help if i were to have
a seizure and lose consciousness
this just got fda approved as the first
smart watch to get approved in neurology
[Music]
now the next slide is what made my skin
conductance go up
one morning i'm checking my email and i
see a story from a mom
who said she was in the shower and her
phone was on the counter by the shower
and it said
her daughter might need her help so she
interrupts her shower and goes running
to her daughter's bedroom
and she finds her daughter face down in
bed blue and not breathing
she flips her over human stimulation
and her daughter takes a breath and
another breath
and her daughter turns pink and is fine
i think i turned white reading this
email
my first response is oh no it's not
perfect the bluetooth could break the
battery could die all these things could
go wrong don't rely on this
and she said it's okay i know no
technology is perfect
none of us can always be there all the
time
but this this device plus ai
enabled me to get there in time to save
my daughter's life
now i've been mentioning children but
sued up
peaks actually among people in their 20s
30s and 40s
and the next line i'm going to put up is
probably going to make some people
uncomfortable
but it's less uncomfortable than we'll
all be if
this list is extended to somebody you
know
could this happen to somebody you know
and the reason i bring up this
uncomfortable question
is because one in 26 of you will have
epilepsy at some point
and from what i've been learning people
with epilepsy often don't tell their
friends and their neighbors that they
have it
so if you're willing to let them use
an ai or whatever to
summon you in a moment of possible need
if you would let them know that
you could make a difference in their
life
why do all this hard work to build ai's
a couple of reasons here
one is natasha the girl who lived and
her family wanted me to tell you
her name another is her family
and the wonderful people out there who
want to be there to support people who
have conditions that they've felt
uncomfortable in the past
mentioning to others and the other
reason is
all of you because we have the
opportunity
to shape the future of ai we can
actually
change it because we are the ones
building it so let's build ai
that makes everybody's lives better
thank you
you